a nation in mourning and tears from the
supreme leader for Iran's top military
general assassinated in the US drone
strike in Iraq Ayatollah Khomeini a
friend of customs of the money led the
funeral service at the Iran University
outside the streets of the capital were
packed with Iranians who considered
selamanya hero a man who defended his
country crowds like this have not been
seen since the death of the founder of
the Islamic Republic
I had to LA Khamenei 30 years ago Salam
on his daughter addressed the crowds
today the philosophy and struggle of my
father has made the resistance front
into a principled and victorious
philosophy soleimani and Iran have long
supported Palestinian groups a senior
Hamas leader Ismail Haniyeh paid his
respects we're here to express our
heartfelt condolences to the leader of
the Islamic Revolution Ayatollah
Khomeini general Soleimani 's family and
the flag bearers of the resistance
against the Zionist regime in the u.s.
the crowds chanted sang and cried the
morning would result in people coming
out in celebration or coming out against
the political establishment in Iran well
the number of mourners here out in that
one show that he was greatly mistaken
there were chants of death to America
and an expectation that Iran must
respond we should take revenge the
feeling that I had towards the general
it's unique I don't have this feeling
towards anyone else in government
there's no one is valuable as the
general but we will answer blood with
blood I want to tell the world and that
stupid president that they killed the
general but we will continue his path
and they cannot do a damn thing since I
heard the news I've been crying and it's
a weird feeling but at the bottom of our
heart we want revenge revenge revenge
but not everyone agrees on what action
to take and there are internal political
struggles in Parliament
the best response is to expel US forces
from the Middle East and make efforts to
liberate Palestine but the specific
response of Iran shouldn't be hasty and
should be well considered an important
body called the Assembly of Experts
condemned the killing of Soleimani and
said silence in the face of
assassination would make iran weaker
they called upon young people to
mobilize and prepare to ask American
forces from Iraq as the world awaits
Iran's response the government here will
find it hard to ignore the calls for
revenge and when it's revenge for a man
of Qasem Soleimani standing
it would appear this popular support for
whatever action may follow Assad big al
Jazeera that Ron